on va lire ensemble avec les
téléspectateurs et avec eva on va jouer
autour de la musique parce que c'est
vrai que tu connais très bien la musique
les fans de musique non mais c'est vrai
voilà c'est s'est tu va choisir un de
nos chroniqueurs combats habillés en
cow-boy et qui va monter sur un taureau
mécanique là bas qui voilà donc c'est
très simple vous dit tu dois répondre en
moins de 3 secondes
si tu réponds bien le taureau est normal
si tu réponds mal on accélérera le taux
repo tu choisis une des personnes
il mettra juste le chapeau c'est tout
choisir nos chroniqueurs que tu veux
c'est toi qui décides au support en qui
tu veux qui va sur le taureau
[Applaudissements]
hebbadj tu peux qui alors les bleus
échouent allen a lui même souffert joue
sur la chose et juste le chapeau mais
regarde tu vas aller rejoindre le pour
le cowboy marlboro par contre il a
bouffé les cigarettes mais c'est mon
pote
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est moi juste un chapeau mettez lui
jusqu'au chapeau il est déjà c'est
ridicule comme ça comme ça ça suffit
fabien alors on va déjà regardé femme
est remonté sur le hero ah ben tu peux
montre des femmes ou des jeux trop
grands
[Applaudissements]
colas de l'impôt les attendait pour
l'instant gelé doucement clermont qui va
doucement avons tirée pour l'instant
alors évincé je vais poser des questions
d'accord attention c'est très sain qu'on
réponde en moins de 3 secondes vous
jouez chez vous à shaktoi tombés
d'accord non mais laissez le tranquille
tranquille là elle ne le fait même pas
bougé pour la jeune à tomber attention
qui chante en duo avec diam's le titre
la même veine la même province et par là
même si je vous gêne
[Applaudissements]
chantilly
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon on n'est plus question avant
de quel de quelle ville sont originaires
les rappeurs big flo et oli ou toujours
j
je peux gérer paris et non c'est
toulouse qui parle aux sa vrai qu'on a
beaucoup boys alors la semaine dernière
d'après dernière pour voir benzema
fabien remonte dessus de venir en
afrique au baiia ajusté fans de
christophe maé nolwenn et ou mal de
vivre sans toi
ce qui fait qu'ils sont mais c'est quoi
ta chatte ans on préfère moi c'est tu
appelles demoiselle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu sais quel est le vrai nom
de famille de christophe maé
mais ça se trouve impliqué j'étais tout
petit est alors alors bah moi je connais
très bien le disant allez voir qu'ils
offraient en concert je ne regardais pas
un viol mais s'appelle christophe
martichon bah ouais c'est vrai que ça va
me faire j'adore christophe maillot
charles impôts demain je l'envoie sport
mais c'est vrai que christophe martichon
j'y vais pas quesque of march o sappey
voter martichon joliveau côté marc
pigeon sur les marchés par tout faire
alors oui vas-y oh non non
ça va bien ça va il est vivant ça va pas
bien aller on vient braderont pas
preneur
[Applaudissements]